[Music]
we want the pandemic to end seeing these
women in gambia
but in many african countries it's
mainly men who are getting the jab
with inevitable consequences
in south sudan 70 of people testing
positive for the virus are women why
it's because they're less likely to be
vaccinated
just a quarter of those who've got the
jab there are women
what's behind the gender gap
i'm ben fazeland this figure will bring
it home to you
70
of healthcare workers worldwide are
women
if they're unvaccinated are they really
able to care for those in need the
elderly the more vulnerable and children
who were also at risk of spreading
covert even further
the action finally gets going under the
large mango tree the traditional meeting
point in the small village of oui in
western kenya
nurse harriet and her team hope to
vaccinate 200 villagers against covet
19.
their plan almost fell through
the village is more than an hour from
the nearest clinic and up to the last
moment the team didn't know whether they
would get a vehicle for today's
vaccination campaign at times when we
don't have the vehicle we normally use
motorbikes
to go to the interior villages
because now we
really want to go vaccinate them but
then at the same time we don't have the
means so its forces are to use to use
motorbikes but again motorbikes are not
safe with our
vaccine carriers so that's why sometimes
if it's so hard we just wait for support
support that should actually come from
the capital nairobi 500 kilometers away
just a few months ago the biggest
problem was that richer countries were
not sending enough vaccines
today the capital is well stocked
but the government doesn't have a plan
to get the vaccines to remote parts of
the country
amnesty international activist diana
kichango finds it scandalous that the
most vulnerable people are being
neglected
[Music]
the few people in the middle class who
understood
why we needed the vaccine
took all measures to jump the kill
and that left us falling very very far
behind in terms of
focusing on the priority population
another problem is that many kenyans
don't want to be vaccinated at all
conspiracy theories about rich countries
wanting to halt population growth in
africa through vaccinations are going
viral on social media
fact checker alfonse shiondu tries to
counter online fake news
he's shocked that even politicians are
promoting rumors
one especially controversial video
features the minister of health in
neighbouring tanzania so she's
addressing on why this is very important
to for them to use alternative medicines
why we should not trust
western medicine and stuff like that
that
was very very potentially dangerous and
very very misleading in the way it was
styled because she's saying no vaccines
in tanzania we don't have covet check
this and you will be safe from any viral
infection
in the small village of uwari too just a
few villagers are waiting under the
mango tree for a jab
harriet and her team didn't reach their
target for today
in the end they only managed 130 rather
than the planned 200 vaccinations
they plan to go out to the villages
again tomorrow
if they can get the van
is director of communications and
advocacy at cade germany and ngo
let's just take a little look together
at
this vaccine gender gap in in three
countries namely
india timor-leste and south sudan and
just look at the difference between
women vaccinated and men who've been
given the jab and we're talking about
half or fewer than half
are these
exceptions would you say sabina
thanks for having me i mean to be honest
it doesn't really come as a surprise to
us humanitarians who've been working in
in emergency contexts and societies with
harmful gender norms but these play out
now much more harshly with the covet
pandemic care has been looking at
figures from 24 countries
those three that you cited amongst them
and what came out quite clearly is that
there's a really really stark gender
disparity and inequality when it comes
to access to vaccinations but also
information
and just freedom freedom of movement for
women
and and why the stock difference between
developing and developed countries
i mean for once the developed countries
have been quite quick at uh of course
uh making sure that their own population
is being vaccinated we have the kovacs
initiative uh which uh delivers
vaccination to to developing countries
but it's simply not enough what we have
to consider is what we've seen in the in
the clip just before from kenya the last
mile delivery it's not enough just to uh
provide vaccines and doses but you also
need to invest in healthcare systems you
need to pay health workers you need to
mobilize the communities you need to
ensure logistics pay for cars pay for
for gas etc so there's a whole
logistical chain surrounded by that and
most of the countries that are on this
list in terms of stark gender disparity
and also
not enough vaccination happening are
countries that are suffering from
chronic poverty or that are in crisis
and in conflict situation and that's why
it's even more difficult to reach
reach the most vulnerable and in general
what are the consequences because i
mentioned women are often care providers
and healthcare workers in in many
countries
exactly and that's the main injustice of
around 70 of global health workers both
in the formal and informal sector and
women but they're not being vaccinated
to the same extent as men so they take
care of patients but they're not
protected themselves um also in terms of
access to to health care and and and
other
other essential services women are
really disproportionately affected by
this pandemic and this is why we're
calling really for for a gender
sensitive approach to all vaccination
campaigns and to ensure that women get
the information they need because what
we've also seen in kenya in the clip
before is there are a lot of rumors and
what really concerns care is that
many many women hesitate even if they
are able or would be able to to get a
vaccination because one of the main
rumors around this is a
potential infertility and this really is
something that concerns a lot of women
around the world and makes them hesitant
to to get the jab so again like so often
in this crisis it comes down to an
information campaign that's needed now
the more a virus replicates the higher
the chances a more transmissible variant
uh may occur
uh a variants like delta and omicron due
to the unvaccinated in your opinion
i mean it's difficult to say and i would
leave that to to scientists but what is
clear is we have a stark injustice when
it comes to to global vaccination rates
only six percent of the global south so
far has received at least one one dose
while 80 percent of all vaccinations
happen in the rich countries in ours so
of course i mean secretary general
antonio guterres said right in the
beginning in early 2020 we are not safe
until everyone is safe and this sentence
still stands and unless we really invest
heavily
in the last mile delivery for all people
um to get a vaccination and to
understand what it means for their
safety uh we are not going to be safe in
in our countries regardless of potential
booster shots or next vaccination
campaigns etc we really need to get
everyone on board and it's not uh i mean
it's a complete injustice to think that
uh
your chance of getting a vaccination
depends on on where you live and and how
poor or how wealthy you are and whether
or not you're a man or woman sabina
burka thank you very much for joining us
from care germany great to get those
insights from you
thank you
now recovered from or survived a coveted
infection here's a viewer question for
our science correspondent derek williams
who is considered a covet 19 survivor is
it regardless of its severity this is
really more of a semantic question than
a scientific one but it caught my
attention because i've used the term
here quite often but i've never really
thought about it before so
let's think about it the word
survivor is a pretty dramatic one the
cambridge dictionary defines it
as a person who continues to live
despite nearly dying now
that definition certainly applies to the
many many people in this pandemic who
contracted severe covet 19
but didn't succumb to it but
not necessarily to everyone who tested
positive for the disease
the two members of of my immediate
family who had mild cases of coven 19
for example
they told me they wouldn't describe
themselves as survivors
in scientific literature
the term is often but not exclusively
applied to people who recovered after
having been hospitalized with the
disease
but there are also arguments for
thinking of those who've recovered from
even a mild case as survivors
studies have shown for instance that
there are increased
longer-term risks for them as well of
developing the range of symptoms
commonly known as
long-covered and
and online support groups for the
condition are full of people who got
only a little sick from the initial
infection
but have struggled ever since recovering
with a wide range of ongoing
life-altering complaints
though i don't know anyone personally
who suffers from long coven
i'm certain that many of those who do
would also consider themselves
survivors who have to keep working to
survive every day so
long and short there doesn't seem to be
a really
narrow definition of the word
survivor in the pandemic but
because covet 19 affects people in so
many different ways
that shouldn't come as a surprise
[Music]
derek williams there and finally drug
maker bayern tech has announced that
it's not enough just to get the two
shots of their coronavirus vaccine to
neutralize the omicron barricade variant
the scientists there say three doses of
their vaccine are showing a significant
increase in antibody production
tech has also announced it could have a
new omicron specific vaccine by march
next year
the new omicron variant is spreading
around the world rising uncertainties
and fears that the corona pandemic is
getting worse instead of
being under control
it's still unclear if and how existing
vaccines are protecting against the new
variant of the coronavirus
nice to have you along stay safe and see
you again soon
[Music]